تحتاج شعارات اضراب والكرامه والقصص من
المخربين يشهد شارع الاردني احتجاجات
عديده للمطالبه بتخفيض اسعار المحروقات
التي تضعفت 16 مره خلال عامين ارتفاع في
الاسعار دفع سائقي الشاحنات الى تنظيم
اضرابات متكرره انضم اليها سائقو سيارات
الاجره والحافلات محملين الحكومه الاردنيه
المسؤوليه
ارتفاع اسعار المحروقات يعني خلال 28
قرش التاليه
لان الناس واقفه شاحناتها الان الموضوع
موضوع كرامه
الاضرابات ممتدت لتشمل عددا من المحال
التجاريه التي اغلقت ابوابها تضامنا مع
احتجاج سائقي الشاحنات في محافظات جنوب
البلاد مثل معان والكرك ومادبا ما تسبب في
حاله من الشلل التام وتكدس السلع خاصه في
ميناء العقبه الرئيسي المطلي على البحر
الاحمر